[MUSIC PLAYING]
My name is Grant
Fleming, and I'm
a data scientist at
Elder Research where
I work on data science
consulting projects
with various public
sector clients.
And in that work, along
with a lot of the work
that I'm doing
outside of work work,
I'm having to wrestle with
the issue of fairness and data
science, specifically things
like, how do we make sure
that the predictions being
generated by our models
are fair?
How do we make
sure we're actually
recording the correct
information our data
and not leaving certain
important factors out?
And if we suspect that something
may have snuck in our model,
how do we make sure that
we're able to detect
that element before we deploy
our model and cause harm
intentionally.
Because as we've
seen probably in some
of the news over
the past few years
this is an issue that's, if
not become more widespread,
become more widely known.
For example in
2018, Joy Buolamwini
and her research team at MIT
published the gender shades
work that they did on facial
recognition algorithms
from companies like
Amazon, IBM, and others.
And in this work, they found out
that these facial recognition
facial recognition
algorithms were actually
having much higher error rates
detecting darker skinned faces
versus lighter skinned faces.
And that obviously is
something that we would not
want to see in any
sort of fair model.
Similarly, we saw
something similar in 2019
in the health care sector
where an algorithm furnished
to hospitals throughout
the US, which
was tasked with helping to
allocate treatment to patients
within the hospitals was
systematically underestimating
the health care needs
for black patients
relative to white
patients or patients
from other ethnic groups.
Again, likely a case
of unintended bias,
but nonetheless something that
led to harms in the real world.
And I could spend
[INAUDIBLE] talking
about these issues across the
various different examples
which I'm not including,
but that's not productive.
Maybe what's more
productive, then, is
coming to an understanding of
why this is actually happening.
So from my perspective
at least, it
seems like this is in
large part the result of us
as data scientists thinking
that our tools alone--
the technical tools,
the code, and the data
and the models that
we are able to build--
are enough to solve these
complex social problems.
Like duct tape, we
use them whenever
we can to fix whatever we can.
And some situations are
helped by duct tape,
but duct tape cannot
alone solve everything.
I think that's a
good metaphor here
for how we should
think about it,
or maybe how we
do think about it.
How we should think about
it instead is our toolkit
is not duct tape that should
be used wildly wherever we can,
but rather our toolkit is
one that, along with people
who have the subject matter and
lived expertise in the areas
that we seem to operate
in, they along with us
can lay a brick by brick
a solution to a problem,
or at least get
closer to solving it.
And this is twofold.
We from them can get
a greater appreciation
for the factors that can't be
encoded in our data or
aren't encoded in our data,
but are nonetheless
relevant to our work,
and they in turn
can help us to better diagnose
issues within our models
before they're deployed.
Sounds good.
But how do we actually do this?
How do we actually
do responsible,
ethical, trustworthy,
however you
want to call it, data
science in practice.
It's the million
dollar question,
and a number of researchers are
working to try and answer this.
And to my reading,
it seems like we've
coalesced around the
three main factors that
go into making a
data science project,
we'll just say responsible
data science project.
Those being, first,
fairness in procedures.
So basically, was the project
designed in such a way
that it can be conducted fairly?
Did it include a
diverse range of voices
and all relevant stakeholders?
Next would be fairness
in predictions.
So when the model
is actually built,
does the model
perform equally well
across different
groups within the data?
And the final one being
fairness in outcomes.
So once the actual
process of the model
is sensed down and
is more or less fair
and even if we get relative
fairness in our predictions,
does the impact of
those predictions
actually improve fairness
in the real world?
Are the impacts of those
predictions equitable?
So fairness and
outcomes obviously
is something that's a little
bit harder to measure maybe
than the other two.
But we'll attempt
to talk about it
at least a little bit over the
course of this presentation.
And the way we'll
move forward with this
is going through each of the
three of these in more detail,
and we'll go through this in the
context of a practical example.
But hopefully by
maintaining all three
of these within our projects,
if not doing our projects
in a way that is
perfectly fair, we
will get closer to a fair
responsible data science.
So let's begin with
fairness in procedures.
And where better to
start thinking about that
than ensuring inclusion?
If you don't have a diverse
perspective or diverse group
of perspectives on your project,
in all likelihood something
could slip through that would
cause an unintended harm when
your model is deployed.
This is especially relevant
for someone like me
who not only is a
consultant who's
often coming into a data science
project in a subject matter
context where I have
less expertise than maybe
some of the people
I'm working with,
but also because I'm a
white man and that comes--
that carries with it
certain biases--some of them
benign, some of them harmful--
in how I see the world
and operate within it.
And it's important
for me and the people
I work with on projects
and the clients
I work with that those biases
are checked by the views
that other people can
bring to the table.
And I think critically,
this is something
that is worthy in all projects
besides being the right thing
to do.
Next though would be
reproducible code.
We don't want code that just
runs on our own machines.
This is maybe easier
said than done,
but there are fortunately
within R ecosystem
a number of packages
available for this.
I don't go too much into
detail on what those
are, because so many
other people have already
spoken in depth about these.
I'll reference two of them here.
The first would probably
be Dr. Anna Krystalli.
She has a great
talk called "Putting
the R into reproducible
research", which
you can find by googling.
It should come up.
And then another
person Karthik Ram
delivered a talk at the previous
RStudio conference in 2019.
Google that.
You should find it.
I don't remember the title,
but between the two of them,
they covered a lot of
really great materials
for doing reproducible
work within R.
But back to fairness
and procedures, finally
to wrap this all up,
we want to make sure
that we document everything we
do and every decision we make.
In the same way that we want to
have our code be reproducible
by technical people, we also
want nontechnical people
who may not be able to actually
access our code directly
to be able to pore
through our results
in a way that's easy
for them to interpret,
and that they can
actually evaluate.
And the Google Brain
ethical AI team
has done a lot of
good work on this.
They've come up with
data sheets, model cards,
and audit reports.
So three different sort of
documentation modalities
that you can all think
of is nutrition labels,
I guess, for each
part of the project.
And even though we
don't yet have any way
to do these within R,
hopefully soon there
will be some sort of
R markdown templates
that make this easier for us.
I'm certainly on my own
end trying to put together
a package for it,
and we'll hopefully
have some more updates
on that in the future.
Point being though
if anyone wants
to look at good
examples for these,
they can Google the research
done by Timnit Gebru, Deborah
Raji, and Megan Mitchell.
And for good examples
of model cards,
I specifically
definitely recommend
looking up the TensorFlow
model card toolkit.
So TensorFlow already has built
in functionality for building
model cards, and they
have some good examples
for that there are
things that we may
want to track in our own work.
With that being done, you
have a relatively fair process
in place.
And so you're in good
shape to start now
thinking about fairness
and predictions.
Starting with:
predicting accurately.
This doesn't need a
whole lot of development,
but I include this here
to make sure to point out
that if you do not have
high predictive performance
overall in your model, by no
conception can it be fair.
Even if you perform
equally across groups,
getting a 10% level of
performance across all of them
is meaningless.
And that's going to do you
and the people this model
is hoping to serve
no good whatsoever.
But more subtle and probably
more relevant to the work we do
is predicting equally.
And to explore this
in practical detail
and how we can actually work
on this at own projects, we're
going to go through an example with
the COMPAS Recidivism dataset.
So this is a dataset released
by the public interest group
ProPublica, and what it
tracks is demographic
and criminal records
information of defendants.
And the goal of this is to
take all this information
and use it to predict
whether these defendants will
commit another crime
in the next two years.
Because of the demographic
information within this data,
it's often used as
sort of the iris
or Titanic dataset
for fairness methods
and evaluation of fairness
maintaining approaches
within data science.
As we're about to do here,
and as I already did here. So
on this plot we can
see two different bars,
one for the accuracy of
a logistic regression
and one for the accuracy
of a random forest model.
And again, these are taking
demographic and criminal
history features and
predicting a binary yes/no,
will commit a crime,
will not commit a crime
within two years.
We can see that they perform
roughly the same, nothing
really jumping out here,
which is why maybe we
want to dig a little deeper.
Maybe we can look at
per-group metrics.
So in this case,
instead of just looking
at overall model
performance, we'll
still look at the performance
of one model versus the other.
But we're going to
look at it with respect
to a protected feature
or sensitive feature,
in this case, race, and then
the protected groups a.k.a.
the levels of that feature which
in this case would be Hispanic,
Other, Caucasian,
or African-American.
And already here we
can see that there's
some differences or
disparities in performance
coming to the fore.
With African-Americans
specifically the model
getting the lowest accuracy
for African-Americans
relative to other groups.
This is already a pretty
compelling result I think.
It goes to show that overall
metrics alone are not
enough to be able
to identify when
you may have some issues of
unfairness in your model.
But we still don't
necessarily know
why these disparities exist.
These disparities have to be
in part due to different rates
of error.
And we don't know whether
that's more false positives
or false negatives for
the different groups.
So let's actually look at
plots of error direction.
And here is where we start to
see the real compelling causes
come to the fore here.
With, in this case, the model hitting
a almost four times higher
false positive rate error
for African-Americans
and Caucasians, and
similarly high rates
for other non-Caucasian groups.
This is clearly
an issue of bias.
And if we were not to rectify
this or communicate this
to our clients or the
non-technical people
we're working with
in this project
and we were to just
put a stamp on this
and let it go, in
the real world,
this would perpetuate
all sorts of biases
that would be harmful.
And we don't want that.
So to get a better context
to that before we actually
communicate those
conclusions, maybe we
want to be able
to say, OK, we've
made every comparison between
every different groups
of Caucasians with
African-Americans, Caucasians
with Hispanics, and maybe
we care specifically
about the relative performance.
So we want to look
at the differences.
That's where fairness
metrics come in.
They don't measure
absolute performance.
They measure relative.
When we look at it
on this plot here,
it's still the same y-axis,
still the same x-axis,
but now we get the percentages
of false positive rates
for each group relative to the
privileged group Caucasians.
And again, we can
see here that there's
quite a lot of disparity.
Why though?
What is it in the
features that are
going into the model,
that are causing
these disparities to exist?
It gets hard to get at causality
at any point within data
science, but if we want to at
least understand more about how
the features impact these
predictions differently,
we don't want to look at
interpretability methods.
And these are often explained
in the context of the black box,
hence the image on the right.
What they allow us to do
is open this black box,
because a lot of these
interpretability methods
are model agnostic, and they
can be used even on models
like XGBoost or random
forest to generate
the sort of explanations maybe
not quite to the same level
fidelity, but
approximately that we
would get from a linear model
like a linear regression
or something like
logistic regression.
I'm not going to go
through these in detail
within this presentation
because the visuals for them
are a little complex, and
we don't have a lot of time.
But I will mention
that they come
in two main varieties, the
first being global methods, which
explain the average
effective features globally.
You can think of this
as like the coefficient
of a regression.
And if you want to
read more about them,
you can look up something like
permutation feature importance,
which ought to be well
known to a number of people,
partial dependence plots,
or individual conditional
expectation plots.
We can also look at
something in the category
of the local methods,
and this could
be say LIME or Shapley values or
derivatives of either of those.
And these are really
powerful because they
allow us to say for an
individual prediction on one
observation,
each feature value we can
quantify the exact amount
that it contributed
into the prediction.
So if someone were
to ask, hey, why
did I get this specific
classification from your model?
You can tell them this
feature contributed this much,
this contributed
this much, et cetera.
A lot of useful
explanation there.
Hopefully this is something
that we can end up
applying to most of our
models, and it's certainly
a set of techniques which are
well developed within the R package
ecosystem currently.
The IML package by Christoph
Molnar is available.
And I use it in my work,
and I think it's fantastic.
But there's also
the vip and DALEX--
D-A-L-E-X I believe--packages
which include a number
of interpretability
methods as well.
And that all about wraps up the
fairness and prediction side.
So again, if you're
able in your own work
to ensure those three
main points are hit,
then you're well on your way to
having more fair predictions,
which then leads us
to the thorny issue
and possible future-looking
set of solutions for fairness
in outcomes.
And why is this future--
why is this future leaning?
Why is this a thorny
set of issues?
Well, outcomes are all
about the consequences
and how we consider fairness in
the context of the real world.
Because these outcomes
and the impacts
that they have on people are
not necessarily something
that we can measure in
the data or at least can--
or at least do measure in the
data, it's something that
requires conversations, not
just with the people who
may be we're working with
who are non-technical
who have the subject matter
expertise for the projects
we're working on, but also the
people impacted by the models.
And talking with all
these different groups
and coming up with some
conception of fairness
to say, OK, maybe
we're going to optimize
for certain predictions despite
these predictions coming
at a loss of predictive
performance for our model,
because ultimately that's
the equitable thing to do.
That's something that's
very project specific.
It doesn't make a lot of
sense for me or anyone else
to give any sort of real
definitive guidance on that.
And just for a little
bit more detail, maybe
an example to make this clear,
you can think of fairness
in outcomes as being relevant
in a case where maybe we're
granting, deciding whether
someone deserves a scholarship,
binary yes/no.
A yes would benefit
someone who comes
from maybe a more disadvantaged
background much more
than someone who comes from
a more privileged background.
And again that's not
necessarily something
we measure within our model.
But if it's something we
want to try and work towards,
then we need to make
sure to mitigate the bias
that we see in our model in a
specific way to serve that end.
And that's where bias
mitigation techniques come in.
And I have the star on word
there from the previous slide
because these techniques,
they sometimes work well,
they sometimes don't.
But by and large they
all have tradeoffs.
And that's because you're
either modifying the data,
in the case of
pre-processing, that
goes into the model
itself, or the predictions
that come out of the model to
reach some notion of fairness.
And while that may improve that
specific notion of fairness,
you may see that
there are losses
and predictive
performance or fairness
across other dimensions.
And to show this,
we'll go back and look
at the COMPAS example.
So here, I have
a plot again that
shows protected groups on the
y-axis and false positive rate
on the x-axis.
But now we're looking instead
of at logistic regression
and random forest, we're looking
at just the random forest.
But we're looking at two
sets of predictions here.
One where the prediction
thresholds are all set at 0.54.
If you have a higher
than 0.5, will
predict that you will commit
a crime, lower the opposite.
In one it's set to an optimal
level for each class such
that it minimizes
false positive rate.
And we can see here
that it does that well.
All groups actually
have a large decrease
in false positive
rate, which is great,
at least relative to each other.
We need to actually
go back a few levels
to look at the per
group performance
metrics on the absolute basis
to see what happened there.
And when we do that
unfortunately we
see that most of the gains
and fairness that we made
in that previous
plot are actually
due to the error rate mostly
increasing for the groups,
but increasing for the
other groups more than
it did for the
African-American group.
So basically what happened
here is the model said, OK, you
want to make it more fair across
groups for false positive rate,
we'll make it so that the
other groups have more error
and make it so that the
African-American group,
their error relative
to the other groups
is lower than it was originally.
Again, if fairness is our
goal here, that's fine.
That's not a bad result.
However, it clearly
did come with the tradeoff.
And whenever we
use these methods,
this is just something
we'll have to consider.
Lastly, for fairness
in outcomes,
we want to consider
the possibility
of algorithmic recourse.
So if our models are making
decisions about people,
we don't want them
to lose the ability
to actually have some
influence over that decision.
They should be
able to appeal it.
They should be able to ask for
explanations as to why they
were given that decision, and
they should be given, if asked
or if they choose to ask,
recommendations for what
they can do to change it.
For more info on
this I recommend
looking at the work of
Ruha Benjamin, William
Isaac, or Shakir Mohamed.
Google any of those
names, and you'll come up
with a lot of good stuff.
And at that point, you
had fairness in outcomes,
you had all three of the
main notions of fairness that
have come up across
the research,
and you're doing a solid job
at doing data science more
responsibly.
And fundamentally that's great,
because doing data science
in this way is the
right thing to do.
There's a lot of good
moral justifications
for why we should do
our work with a greater
conception of fairness and
consider factors outside
of the code and the
data and the predictions
that we normally deal with.
Maybe as a profession we should
start thinking of ourselves
not just as data scientists,
but also ethnographers,
sociologists, anthropologists.
Not just thinking about
it though, actually
getting that
knowledge, and that's
something we should seek out.
But beyond being right--
or beyond being the
morally right thing to do,
I also want to make
one more point.
This is not just the
right thing to do.
Doing these practices, and doing
data science more responsibly
in this way is doing
better data science.
By doing responsible
data science
you'll build better
models, you'll
have less errors sneaking
through to model deployment,
and fundamentally you'll
be serving all the people
that you're already serving
much better than you
are now and with a greater
eye to safety and fairness.
And if that's not worth doing,
then I don't know what is.
So what I have here
to wrap up with
are a few resources, additional
links that people can look at.
But I have a number of
other resources in addition
to code to generate those plots
and do a few other analyses
on the GitHub.
So if you're interested,
please do check that out.
But otherwise, thanks
for coming to the talk
and for sitting here with me.
And hope to connect
with you soon
and see you using these
techniques yourself.
Best of luck.
[MUSIC PLAYING]